si el enfermo
en febrero del 2001
[Aplausos]
nosotros es el candidato a la
presidencia de ecuador andrés arauz y
así se define él mismo en su biografía
de 'twitter' patriota demócrata
progresista candidato a la presidencia
del ecuador nunca me niego a un ceviche
jipijapa junto con su candidato
vicepresidencial carlos rabascall forman
el llamado binomio de la esperanza
además están apadrinados por el ex
presidente rafael correa al que arauz
lleva en los mítines en un cartón a
tamaño real
de hecho durante la presidencia de
correa fue ministro entre 2015 y 2017 de
conocimiento y talento humano y durante
unos meses ministro de cultura ahora
pese a su juventud a los 36 años podría
convertirse en el presidente más joven
de la historia de ecuador
[Música]
nacido en quito habla inglés francés y
ruso y es graduado en economía por la
universidad de michigan define sus
políticas como post keynesianas sociales
y solidarias su objetivo recuperar el
progresismo de la presidencia de rafael
correa una meta que le ha llevado al
consejo ejecutivo de la internacional
progresista donde participan figuras
como el senador demócrata de bernie
sanders el ex ministro de finanzas
griego yannis varoufakis o el
vicepresidente del gobierno español
pablo iglesias ingleses fuera de serie
ahí está un currículum y creo que va a
ser un gran presidente del web
tras el anuncio de su candidatura muchos
se preguntaban quién era el respondía
que 'el perfecto desconocido' y en plena
pandemia con la campaña virtualizada se
presenta mediante una canción en redes
sociales
[Música]